The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: A quick review of
what we talked about last time.
So the first thing
we did last time
was to discuss the
age of universe,
considering so far
only at this point,
flat matter-dominated universes
where the scale factor goes
like t to the 2/3.
And we were easily able to see
that the age of such a universe
was 2/3 times h inverse.
And we did discuss what
happens if you plug-in numbers
into that formula using the
best current value of h,
the value obtained by the
Planck team last March.
The age turns out to be about
9.5 to 9.9 billion years.
And that can't be the real
age of the universe, we think,
because there are stars
that are older than that.
The age of the stars
seems to indicate
that the university
should be at least,
according to one paper I cited
last time, 11.2 billion years
old, and this is younger.
So the conclusion is
that our universe is not
a flat, moderate,
matter-dominated universe.
We do in fact have good evidence
that the universe is very
nearly flat, so it's the
matter-dominated part that
has to fail, and it does fail.
We also have good evidence that
the universe is dominated today
by dark energy, which we'll
be talking about later.
But one of the pieces of
evidence for this dark energy
is this age calculation.
The age calculation
just does not
work unless you assume
that the universe has
a significant component
of this dark energy, which
we'll be discussing later.
We then talked about the
big bang singularity,
which is an important part of
understanding, when you talk
about the age, what exactly
you mean by the age, age
since when.
And the point that
I tried to make
there is that the big bang
singularity, which gives us
mathematically the
statement that the scale
factor at some time which we
call zero was equal to zero,
and if you put back that
formula into other formulas,
you discover that the
mass density, for example,
was infinite at this magical
time that we call zero.
That singularity is certainly
part of our mathematical model
and doesn't go away
even when we make
changes in the
mathematical model.
But we don't really know
if it's an actual feature
of our universe, because
there's certainly no reason
to trust this mathematical
model all the way back to t
equals zero, where the
densities become infinite.
We know a lot
about matter and we
think we can predict
how matter will behave,
even the temperatures and
energy densities somewhat
beyond what we
measure in laboratory.
But we don't think
we can't necessarily
extrapolate all the way to
infinite matter density.
So these equations
do break down when
you get very close
to t equals zero
and nobody really knows exactly
what should be said about t
equals zero.
When we talk about
the age, we're
really talking about the age
since the extrapolated time
at which a would have
been zero in this model,
but we don't really know that
it ever actually was zero.
We next discussed the concept
of the horizon distance.
If the universe, at
least the universe
as we know it, we want to be
agnostic about what happened
before t equals zero, but
certainly the universe as we
know it, really began at
t equals zero in the sense
that that's when structure
and complicated things
started to develop.
So since t equals zero there's
been only a finite amount
of time elapsed.
And since light travels
at a finite speed,
that means that light
could only have traveled
some finite distance since the
big bang, since t equals zero.
And that means that
there's some object which
is the furthest possible
object that we could see,
and any object further than
that would be in a situation
where light from that
object would not yet
have had time to reach us.
And that leads to this notion
of our horizon distance,
where the definition
of the horizon distance
is that it is defined to be the
present distance of the most
distant objects which we
are capable of seeing,
limited only by
the speed of light.
And once able to calculate that,
and in particular for the model
that we so far
understood at this point,
the matter-dominated
flat universe,
the horizon distance turned
out to be three times c t.
Tt
Now remember, if the
universe were just static
and appeared at time t ago,
then the horizon distance
would just be c t, the
distance that light
could travel in time t.
What makes it larger is the fact
that the universe is expanding,
and that means that
everything was closer together
in the early time and
light could make more
progress at the early time, and
then these objects have since
moved out to much
larger distances.
So that allows the horizon
distance to be larger than c t,
and in this particular
model, it's three times c t.
Next we began a
calculation, which
is what we're going to
pick up to continue on now.
We were calculating how to
extend our understanding of a
of t, the behavior
of the scale factor,
away from the flat case,
to ultimately discuss
the two other cases, the
open and closed universe.
And we decided on
a flip of a coin--
I promise you I flipped
a coin at some point--
to start with the
closed universe.
We could have done
either one first.
The equation that we start
with is basically the same,
it's the sine of k that
makes the difference.
This is the so-called
Friedmann equation,
and for a closed
universe k is positive.
This is the evolution
equation, but it
has to be coupled
with an equation that
describes how rho
behaves with time.
And for a
matter-dominated universe,
rho is just representing
non-relativistic matter,
which is nothing but spread
as the universe expands.
And the spreading
gives a factor of one
over a cubed as the
volume grows as a cubed.
And that means that rho
times a cubed is a constant,
and that expresses
everything that there
is to know about how
rho behaves with time.
OK, then after writing
these equations,
we said that things will
simplify a little bit, not
a lot, but a little bit if we
redefine variables basically
to incorporate all the constants
that appear in these equations
into one overall constant.
And we decided, or I
claimed, that a good way
to do that, an economical
way to do that,
is to define things so
that the variables all
have units which are
easily understood.
And in this case
the units of length
can describe everything
that we need,
so we chose to
express everything
in terms of variables
that have units of length.
So the scale factor itself
is units of meters per notch,
and that's not a length.
And notches we'd like
to get rid of because we
know they're un-physical.
That is, there's no standard
for what the notch should be.
So if we divide a of t
by the square root of k,
the notches
disappear, and we get
something which just
has the units of meters,
or units of length, and I
call that a twiddle of t.
Similarly, but more obviously,
t can be turned into a length
by just multiplying by
c, the speed of light.
So I defined a variable t
tilde which is just c times t.
So both of these new
variables, with the tildes,
have units of length.
And then the
Friedmann equation can
be rewritten, just
reshuffling things
according to these new
definitions, in this way where
all the constants are lumped
into this variable alpha, where
alpha is this complicated
expression, which absorbs all
the constants from
the earlier equation.
Alpha also has units
of length, and even
though it has a rho times
a tilde cubed in it,
and both rho and a tilde
each depend on time,
the product of rho times a tilde
cubed is a constant because rho
times a cubed is a constant
and a tilde differs only
by the square root of k,
which is also a constant.
So alpha is a constant
even though it
has time dependent factors.
The time dependence
of those two factors
cancel each other
out to give something
which is time independent and
can be evaluated any old time.
So this now is our equation, and
we proceeded to manipulate it.
So the first thing we did
was to take it's square root,
and to rearrange it so that d
t tilde appeared on one side,
and everything else
was on the other side.
And everything else
depends on a tilde
but not explicitly on time.
So this completely
separates everything
that depends on t
tilde on the left,
and everything that depends
on a tilde on the right.
And now we can just integrate
both sides of that equation,
and and they point to that,
that there are basically
two ways of proceeding
here, one of which
we already did when
we did the flat case.
When we did the flat case,
we integrated both sides
as indefinite integrals.
And when you carry out an
indefinite integration,
you get a constant
of integration,
which then becomes a
constant in your solution.
And in that case we discovered
that the constant really
just shifted the origin of time.
And since we had not said
anything previously that
in any way determined
the origin of time,
we used that constant to
arrange the origin of time
so that a of zero
would equal zero,
and that eliminated
the constant.
Just for variety, I am going
to do it another way this time.
Instead of doing an
indefinite integral,
I will do a definite integral.
And if you do a
definite integral,
you have to make sure
you're integrating
both sides over the
same range, or at least
corresponding ranges.
We have different names
for the variables,
but the range of
integration of the two sides
has to match in
order to maintain
the equality between
the two sides.
So we're going to integrate
the left side from zero
to some final time.
And I'm going to call the
final time t tilde variable sub
f, for f to stand for final.
And there's no real
final time here.
It could be any time,
it's just the final time
for the integration,
and in the end
discover then how things
behave at time t tilde sub f.
And then once we've figured
that out we can drop the effort.
It will be a formula that
will be valid for any time.
So the left hand side
is integrated from zero
to time t tilde f,
the right hand side
has to be integrated over the
corresponding time interval.
And we would like to define a
tilde and the origin of time
so that a tilde equals
zero at time zero,
the same convention we
used for the other case.
The standard convention in
cosmology, t equals zero,
is the instance of the Big Bang.
And the instance of the
Big Bang is the time
at which the scale
factor vanished.
So that means when we have
a lower limit of integration
of t tilde equals zero
on the left hand side,
we should have a lower
limit of integration
of a tilde equals zero
on the right hand side.
And similarly the upper
limits of integration
should correspond to each other.
So the upper limit of
integration on the left hand
side was t tilde sub f,
really just an arbitrary time
that we designated
by the subscript f.
So the right hand
side the limit should
be the value of a
tilde at that time.
And I'll call that
a tilde sub f.
So a tilde sub f is
just defined to be
the value of a tilde at
the time t tilde sub f.
And in this way the limits of
integration on the two sides
correspond and now
we can integrate them
and we don't need any new
integration constants.
These definite integrals
have definite values,
which is why they're called
definite integrals, I suppose.
OK any questions about
that, because that's
where we're ready to take off
and start doing new material.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a
general question.
So regarding the issue of
how we're not really sure how
to extrapolate up
to t equals zero,
this is just kind of
a general question.
I was wondering how
we're kind of assuming
throughout that time
kind of flows uniformly,
and so I've heard
about something
like gravitational
time dilation.
So at the beginning
especially when there's
such a high density of
matter or radiation,
then wouldn't that affect
how, I guess, time flows?
PROFESSOR: OK good
question, good question.
The question was, does things
like general realistic time
dilation affect how
time flows, and are we
perhaps being overly simplistic
and assuming that time just
flows smoothly from
time zero onward.
The answer to that is that
general relativity does
predict an extra
time dilation, which
in fact is built into the
Doppler shift calculation
that we already did.
And there are other instances
where similar things happen.
If a photon travels from
the floor of this room
to the ceiling of
this room, there's
a small Doppler shift, a
small shift in the timing.
And you could see it in
principle with clocks as well.
If you had a clock on the floor,
and a clock on the ceiling,
they would not run at
quite the same rate.
But to talk about time
dilation, you always
have to have two
clocks to compare.
In the case of the
universe, we have this thing
that we call cosmic time, which
can be measured on any clock.
The homogeneity
assumption implies
that all clocks will
do the same thing,
so so the issue of time
dilation really does not arise.
Our definition of
cosmic time defines
time that is the time
variable that we will use.
And when we say it flows
uniformly from zero up
to the present time, that word
uniformly sounds sensible.
But if you think about it,
I don't know what it means.
So I don't even know how to ask
if it's really uniform or not.
It's certainly true
that our time variable
evolves from zero up
to some final time,
but smoothly or uniformly
is not really a question we
can ask until one has some other
clock that one can compare it
to.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you
said at the beginning
that something like
an infinite density
is just an effect
of our equation.
Aren't a lot of theories
like inflation come out
of assuming that the
universe had gotten
some infinite,
dense, small area?
So what effect does this
assumption that may or may not
be correct have on theories?
PROFESSOR: OK, the
question is, if we are not
sure we should believe the
t equals zero singularity,
how does that affect other
theories like inflation, which
are based on extrapolating
backwards to very early times.
And there is an answer to that.
The answer may or may
not sound sensible,
and it may or may
not be sensible.
It's hard to know for sure.
But one can be more
detailed and ask
how far back do we think
we can trust our equations?
And nobody really
knows the answer
to that of course, that's
part of the uncertainty here.
But a plausible answer which is
kind of the working hypothesis
for many of us, is that the
only obstacle to extrapolating
backwards is our
lack of knowledge
of the quantum
effects of gravity,
and therefore the
quantum effects
of what space time looks like.
And we can estimate
where that sets in.
And it's at a time called the
Planck time, which is about 10
to the minus 43
seconds, and inflation,
which we'll see later as
sort of a natural timescale
of about probably 10 to
the minus 37 seconds.
So although that's
incredibly small,
it's actually incredibly
large compared
to 10 to the minus 43 seconds.
So we think there is at
least a basis for believing
that things like our discussions
of inflation which we'll
be talking about later, are
valid even though we don't
think we can extrapolate
back to t equals zero.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about use
of the definite integrals.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So we have
a twiddle defined
as a over square root of k.
And we noticed in
our equation that a
goes to zero as t goes to zero,
so a twiddle also goes to zero.
How do we know then that
that definite integral
is convergent,
because then we have
zero over zero competing
case. [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Let me think.
Yeah, we'll see, I
think is the answer.
How do we know it's convergent?
Well, we're going to
actually do the integral,
and then the integral
does converge.
You are right.
The integrand does become zero
over zero, but that in fact
means the integrand is some
finite number actually.
Both numerator and
denominator go to zero,
I mean let me think about this.
I guess a tilde squared
becomes negligible,
so the denominator goes like
one over the square root
of a tilde.
So in fact the numerator
divided by the denominator
goes like the square root of
a tilde as time goes to zero.
Because you have a square
root in the denominator,
the a tilde squared
becomes negligible,
so it's manifestly convergent.
The integrand does
not even blow up,
even though a tilde
does go to zero.
It's certainly worth
looking at, you're right.
One should always check to make
sure integrals are convergent.
But since we will actually be
explicitly doing the interval,
if it was divergent we would
get a divergent answer,
and we will not as you'll
see in a couple minutes.
Any other questions?
OK, so in that case,
to the blackboard.
OK, so I will write
on the blackboard
the same equation we have up
there, so we can continue.
t twiddle f is equal to
the integral from zero
to a twiddle sub f,
a twiddle d a twiddle
over the square
root of two alpha
a twiddle minus a
twiddle squared.
OK, so what we'd
like to do now is
to carry out the integral
on the right hand side.
Ideally what we'd like to do
is to carry out the integral
on the right hand side and
get some function of a tilde f
and then we'd like to
convert that function
to be able to write a tilde
f as a function of time.
We actually won't quite
be able to do that.
We'll end up with what's
called the parametric solution,
and you'll see how that
arises and what that means.
I don't need to try
to describe exactly
in advance what that means.
Doing the integral can
be done by some tricks,
some substitutions.
And the first
substitution is based
on completing the square
in the denominator,
and that motivates the
substitution that we will make.
So we can rewrite this
just by doing some algebra
on the denominator, which
is called completing
the square for
reasons that you'll
see when I write
down what it is.
The numerator will
stay a tilde d a tilde.
And the denominator
can be written
as alpha squared minus a tilde
minus alpha quantity squared.
So completing the
square just means
to put the a tilde
inside a perfect square.
And the nice thing about
this is that now we
can shift our variable
of integration,
and turn this into just
a single variable instead
of the sum of the two.
And then you have
an expression, which
is clearly simpler looking
than this one, which
had a tildes in both places.
Now the variable integration
will appear only there.
And substitution which does
that obviously enough, is we're
going to let something, we
can choose whatever we want,
and then once I call
it x, we're going
to let x equal a
tilde minus alpha.
And we're just going to rewrite
that integral in terms of x.
So what we get when
we do that is t
sub f tilde is equal to the
rewriting of that integral,
and just substituting the a
tilde becomes x plus alpha.
So we get x plus alpha
where a tilde was,
and d a tilde becomes just d x.
And the denominator,
which was our motivation
for making the substitution
in the first place,
becomes just alpha
squared minus x squared.
So this is perfectly
straight forward.
The next step
which is important,
is to get the limits
of integration right,
because with this
definite integral method
we really have to make sure
that our limits of integration
are correct.
So straightforward to do that,
the lower limit of integration
was a tilde equals zero,
and if a tilde equals zero,
x is equal to minus alpha.
So the lower limit
of integration
expressed as a value
of x is minus alpha.
And the upper limit
expressed as x
was a tilde f, and
that means x is
equal to a tilde f minus alpha.
So the limit here is a
tilde sub f minus alpha
for the upper limit
of integration.
OK, now this integral
is still not easy,
but it can be made easy
by one more substitution.
And the one more substitution
is a trigonometric substitution
to simplify the denominator.
We can let x equal
minus alpha cosine
of theta, where theta is our
new variable of integration.
And then alpha squared
minus x squared
becomes alpha
squared minus alpha
squared cosine squared theta.
And the alphas factor out and
you have the square root of 1
minus cosine squared theta.
1 minus cosine squared theta
is sine squared theta, which
is a convenient thing to
take the square root of,
you just get sine theta.
And everything else
also simplifies.
And the bottom line, which
I will just give you,
is that now we find that t sub s
tilde is just the integral of 1
minus cosine theta d theta.
That's it.
Everything simplifies to that
which is easy to integrate.
We also have to keep track
of our limits of integration.
The limit of integration, the
lower limit of integration,
is where x equals minus alpha.
And if x equals
minus alpha, that
means cosine theta equals 1.
And cosine theta equals
1 means theta equals 0.
So the limit of integration on
theta is easy, it starts at 0.
And the final value
is really just a value
that corresponds to
the final value of x
which is a twiddle
f minus alpha.
For now I'm just going
to call it theta sub f.
Things that we have
just determined
is the value of theta that goes
with the upper limit there.
We'll figure out in a second
how to write it more explicitly.
Let me first do the integral to
just get that out of the way.
Doing the integral,
you get alpha times 1
minus cosine theta sub f.
So this in fact becomes
half of our solution.
It expresses t sub f in
terms of theta sub f.
And now that we're done
with the whole problem,
I'm going to drop
the subscript f.
There's just some
time that we're
interested in which is called t
and the value of a at that time
will be called a, and the
value of theta at that time
will be called theta.
So I'm just going to drop
the subscript everywhere
because we are now in a
situation were the subscript is
everywhere, so
dropping everywhere
does not lose any information.
So one of our equations
is going to be
simply t is equal to alpha
times 1 minus cosine theta.
And another equation will
come from figuring out
what theta sub f
really is, which
I said comes from making
sure that the upper limit
of integration here
corresponds to the upper limit
of integration in the
previous integral.
So theta sub f, I
had to determine
this on another blackboard and
then put the final equations
together.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's right
I don't want to drop twiddles.
T twiddle, thank you, is
equal to alpha times 1
minus cosine theta, and and then
we have the final value of x.
Xx x is equal to a
tilde minus alpha.
So the final value of x is
equal to the final value
of a tilde minus alpha.
And the final value of x
is also related to theta
by this equation, which is
what we're trying to get,
how theta is related
to the other variables.
So this is equal to minus
alpha cosine of theta sub f.
And now we might
want to, for example,
solve this for a tilde sub f,
which just involves looking
at the right hand
half of the equation,
bringing this alpha to the
other side making a plus alpha.
So this implies that a tilde
sub f is equal to alpha times 1
minus cosine theta sub f.
So this equation now
just says that theta
sub f means what it
should mean to give us
a final limit of
integration that corresponds
to the final limit
of integration
on our original integral,
which we called a tilde sub f.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sorry,
perhaps I missed it.
But when you are doing
the integral of 1
minus cosine theta, how come--
PROFESSOR: Oh, I got it wrong.
Good point.
The integral of
cosine theta d theta
is sine theta, not cosine theta.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Wait a minute.
Hold on.
Do I still have it wrong?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK hold on.
There was an alpha missing here.
That's part of the
problem, coming
from the original equation here.
Let's see if I have
this right now.
This is copying from a
long line altogether.
So I got both factors wrong.
And then wait a minute.
I think this is right now.
There's still a
wrong [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: If I differentiate
sine, I get cosine.
So if I differentiate minus
sine, I get minus cosine.
So differentiating
this, I get this.
That should mean that
integrating this I get that.
I think I have it right.
Sometimes I get things right.
It's a surprise, but--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: The last
equation you wrote.
PROFESSOR: The last equation
needs to be changed, right.
This was copied
from that, right.
Thanks for reminding me.
So t tilde is equal to alpha
times theta minus sine theta.
OK, and now I was working
out the relationship
between theta and a tilde.
And let me just remind
you that all I did
was make sure that the
upper limits of integration
correspond to each other.
So I'm just basically rewriting
the upper limit of integration
in terms of the new
variable each time
when we change variables
starting from a tilde going
to a tilde to x,
and from x to theta.
And then I use the
equality of these two
to write a tilde
in terms of theta.
And these equations now hold
with the subscript f present.
When subscript f's appear
everywhere we can just
drop them and say that
the time that we called
t sub f now we're
just going to call t.
And now we could put together
our two final results
which are maybe right over here.
We have ct.
I'll eliminate my
tildes altogether now.
ct, which is t tilde, is
equal to alpha times theta
minus sine theta.
And a divided by the
square root of k,
which is a tilde and its sub f,
but we're dropping the sub f,
is equal to alpha times
1 minus cosine theta.
And this is as good as it gets.
Ideally, it would
be nice if we could
solve the top equation for
theta as a function of t,
and plug that into
the bottom equation,
and then we would get
a as a function of t.
That's what ideally
we would love to have.
But there's no way to
do that analytically.
In principle of course, this
equation can be inverted.
You could do it numerically.
For any particular
value of t you
could figure out what value
of theta makes this work,
and then plug that value
of theta into here.
But there's no
analytic way that you
can write theta as
a function of t.
It's not a soluble equation.
So this is called a parametric
solution in the sense
that theta is a parameter.
And as theta varies, both t and
a vary in just the right way
so that a is always related
to t in the correct way
to solve our original
differential equation.
That's what's meant by
a parametric solution.
We can also see
from this equation,
or maybe from thinking back
about how things are defined
in the first place,
how theta varies
over the lifetime of
our model universe.
Theta we discovered starts at 0.
We discovered that when we
wrote our integral over there.
And we could also
probably see it from here.
We start our universe
at a equals 0.
And at a equals 0, we want
1 minus cosine theta to be 0
and theta equals 0 does that.
So theta starts at 0, which
corresponds to a equals 0,
and it also corresponds
putting theta equals 0 here
to t equals 0.
So we have arranged
things the way
we intended so that
a equals 0 happens
the same time t
equals 0 happens.
And then theta starts to grow.
As theta grows, a
increases, the universe
gets bigger until
theta reaches pi.
And when theta reaches pi,
cosine of pi is minus 1,
you get a factor
of 2 here, 2 alpha.
That's as big as
our universe gets.
And then as theta
continues beyond that,
1 minus cosine theta starts
getting smaller again.
So our universe
reaches a maximum size
when theta equals pi, and
then starts to contract.
And then by the time
theta equals 2 pi,
you are back to where
you started from,
a is again equal to 0.
We have universe which starts at
0 size, goes to a maximum size,
goes back to 0 size, giving
a Big Crunch at the end.
And that's the way this
closed universe behaves.
It turns out that these
equations actually
correspond to some
simple geometry.
It corresponds to a cycloid.
And you may or may not
remember what a cycloid is.
There are the equations
written on the screen, which
are hopefully the same equations
that I have on the blackboard.
Can't always count on
these things it turns out.
But yeah, they are the same
equations, that's healthy.
And I have a diagram
here which explains
this cycloid correspondence.
A cycloid is defined as what
happens in this picture.
Let me explain the picture.
We have a disk shown
in the upper left
in its original position
with a dot on the disk, which
is initially at the bottom.
And initially we're
going to put this disk
at the origin of our
coordinate system
to make things as
simple as possible.
And then we're going to
imagine that this disk rolls
without slipping to the right.
And the path that
this dot traces out,
which is shown along that line,
is a cycloid by definition.
That's what defines a cycloid.
It's the path that a point on
a rolling disk evolved through.
So what I would like
to do is convince you
that this geometric picture
corresponds to those equations.
Let me put the equations
higher to make sure everybody
can see them.
And it's actually
not so complicated
once you figure out how
to parse the pictures.
So what I've drawn in the upper
right is a blow up of this disk
after it's rolled
through some angle theta.
And I even made it the same
angle theta in the two cases.
But this is just
a bigger version
of what's in the corner there
showing the disk after it
rolled a little bit.
So after it's rolled
through an angle theta, what
we want to verify is that
the horizontal and vertical
coordinates here correspond
to these two equations.
And if they do, it means
that we're tracing out
the behavior of
those two equations.
So look first at the
horizontal component.
The horizontal component
is the ct axis.
So that should correspond
to alpha times theta
minus alpha times sine theta.
And you can see
that in the picture.
We're talking about the
horizontal component
of the coordinates
of this point P.
And the point is
that you can get
to P starting at the origin.
Now remember we're only
looking at horizontal motion
so we could start
anywhere on that line.
We could start at the origin,
go to the right by alpha theta,
and to the left by alpha times
sine theta, and we get there.
And that's exactly
what this formula says.
So if we just understand the
alpha theta and the alpha sine
theta of those two
lines we have it made.
So let's look first
at what happens where
this first arrow comes
from, the alpha theta line.
That's just the total distance
that the point of contact
has moved during
the rolling process.
And the claim is that
as something rolls,
really the definition of
rolling without slipping,
is that the arc length that
is swept out by the rolling
is the same as the length
along the surface on which it's
rolling.
You could imagine, if
you like, that as it
rolls there's a
tape measure that's
wrapped around it that gets
left on the ground as it rolls.
And if you could
picture that happening,
the existence of
that movie really
guarantees that the
length on the ground
is the same as what the length
was when the tape measure was
wrapped around the cylinder.
So the length that the
point of contact has moved
is just alpha times
the angle through which
the disk is rolled.
So that explains the alpha
theta label on that line.
To get the alpha sine
theta on the line above,
that's the distance
between the point P
and a vertical line that goes
through the center of the disk.
And that's just simple
trigonometry on this triangle.
The radius of our
circle is alpha.
And then by simple
trigonometry, this length
is alpha times sine theta,
which is what the label says.
So to summarize
what we've got here
we can find the x-coordinate
of the horizontal
according to the
point P by going
to the right a
distance alpha theta,
and then back to the left the
distance of minus alpha theta.
And that gives us
an x-coordinate,
which is exactly the formula
that appears in the ct formula.
So ct works.
The horizontal
component of that dot
is just where it should be to
trace out the equations that
describe the evolution
of a closed universe.
Similarly we can now look
at the vertical components
of that dot.
Again it's most easily
seen as the difference
of two contributions.
We're trying to reproduce this
formula that says that's alpha
minus alpha cosine theta.
So if we start at vertical
coordinate 0, which
means on the
x-axis, we can begin
by going up to the
center of the disk.
And the disk has
radius alpha, so that's
going up the distance alpha.
And then we go down the distance
of this piece of the triangle,
going from the
center of the disk
to the point which is
parallel to the point P.
And that again is just
trigonometry on that triangle,
and it's alpha cosine theta
by simple trigonometry.
So we can get to the
elevation of point P
by going up by alpha and down
by alpha times cosine theta.
And that's exactly that formula.
So it works.
The x and y components,
the horizontal
and vertical
components of that dot,
are exactly the
two formulas here.
So one of them can be thought of
as the x-axis, and one of them
can be thought of as the y-axis.
And the rolling of the
disk just traces out
the evolution of
our closed universe.
So closed universes
evolve like a cycloid.
Any questions about that?
OK, great.
OK, Let me just mention that
this angle theta is sometimes
given a name.
It's called the development
angle of the universe
or of the solution.
And that is just intended to
have the connotation that theta
describes how developed
the universe is
and theta has a fixed scale.
It always goes from 0 to
2 pi over the lifetime
of this closed
universe, no matter
how big the closed
universe might be.
That brings me to my next
question I want to mention.
How many parameters do
we have in this solution?
The way we've
written it, it looks
like it can depend on both
alpha and k because both of them
appear in the answer.
And k is positive for
our closed universes.
These formulas will not make
sense if k were negative,
square root of k appears there.
We don't want anything
to be imaginary.
But k can have any
value in principle
and these equations
would still be valid.
So on the surface it appears
like there's a two parameter
class of closed
universe solutions.
But that's actually not true.
Can somebody tell me
why it's not true?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Yes, since k has units
of 1 over notch squared,
you can change k to
anything you want
by changing your
definition of a notch.
And there's nothing fixed about
the definition of a notch.
So k is an irrelevant parameter.
If we change k we're just
rescaling the same solution,
and not actually
creating a new solution.
So there's really only one
parameter class of solutions.
One could, for example,
fix k to always be 1,
and then we'd have
a one parameter
class of solutions
indicated by alpha.
Alpha, unlike k, really does
have a clear, physical meaning
related to the behavior
of the universe.
And we could see
what that is if we
ask, what is the total lifetime
of this universe from beginning
to end, from Big
Bang to Big Crunch.
We can answer that by just
looking at the ct equation.
From Big Bang to Big Crunch, we
know that theta evolves from 0
to pi back to 2 pi,
which is the same as 0.
So theta goes through
one cycle of 2 pi
during a lifetime of
our model universe.
As theta goes from 0 to 2
pi, sine theta starts at 0
and eventually comes back
to 0 when theta equals 2 pi.
But theta increases from
0 to 2 pi over one cycle.
So over one cycle
of our universe,
ct increases by
alpha times 2 pi.
So that tells us what the
total lifetime of the universe
is, I'll call it t total.
And we get it by just writing
c times t total equals 2 pi
times alpha.
And I think I can do this one
without making a mistake. t
total is then 2 pi
alpha divided by c.
And we can even check
our units there.
Alpha has units of length,
so length divided by c
becomes a time, c
being a velocity.
So it has the right units.
And that's the total
lifetime of the universe.
It's just determined by alpha.
So alpha can be viewed
as just the measure
of the total lifetime of the
universe, which can be anything
for different sized
closed universes.
Alpha is also related to the
maximum value of a over root k.
And a has no fixed meaning,
this is meters per notch.
But a over root k does
have units of meters.
We haven't yet really seen
what it means physically,
because that's related to the
geometry of the closed universe
which we'll be discussing later.
But in any case as
a mathematical fact,
we could always say that the
maximum value of a over root k
is determined by alpha.
So a max over root k is
equal to the maximum value
of this expression.
And this expression
has a maximum value
when theta equals pi,
which gives cosine theta
equals minus 1,
which gives a 2 here.
And that's as big
as it ever gets,
so that's just equal to 2 alpha.
So alpha is related in a very
clear way to the total lifetime
of our universe, and is
also related to a over root
k, although we
haven't really given
a physical meaning
to a over root k yet.
But we know it has
dimensions of meters.
OK, the next
calculation I want to do
is to calculate the
age of the universe
as a function of
measurable things.
We learned for the flat
matter dominated case
that there was a
simple answer to that.
The age was just 2/3 times
the inverse Hubble parameter.
So what you do now is get
the analogous formula here,
it follows in
principle immediately
from our description
of the evolution.
But we have to do a fair
number of substitutions
before we can really see how
to express the age in terms
of things that
we're interested in.
The formula here
tells us directly
how to express the
age of the universe. t
is the age of the universe as
a function of alpha and theta.
But if you tell an astronomer
to go out and measure alpha
and theta so I could
calculate the age,
he says what in the world
are alpha and theta.
So what we'd like to do
is to express the age
in terms of things that
astronomers know about.
And the characterizations
of the universe
like this that an
astronomer would know about
would be the Hubble
expansion rate,
and some notion of
the mass density.
And the easiest way to
talk about the mass density
is in terms of
omega, the fraction
of the critical density that
the actual mass density has.
So our goal is going to be to
manipulate these equations.
All the information
is already there.
But our goal will be to
manipulate these equations
to be able to express the age
t in terms of h and omega.
OK, so first we need to remind
ourselves what omega is.
The critical density is
defined as that density
which makes the universe flat.
And we've calculated that
the critical density is
equal to 3 h squared
over 8 pi times newtons
constant, capital G. We can
then write the mass density rho
as omega times the
critical density,
which is just the
definition of omega.
Omega is rho divided by rho c,
the actual mass density divided
by the critical density.
And putting what rho c
is, we can express rho
as 3h squared omega divided by
8 pi G. And being very pedantic,
I'm just going to
rewrite that in the form
that we're actually going to
use it by multiplying through.
8 pi over 3 G rho,
taking these factors
and bringing them
to the other side,
becomes just equal to
h squared times omega.
And you might recognize
this particular combination
as what appears in the
Friedmann equation.
The Friedmann equation told
us that a dot over a squared
is equal to 8 pi over
3 G rho, minus kc
squared over a squared.
And in order to get the
substitutions that I want,
I'm going to just
rewrite this putting
h squared for a
dot over a squared.
8 pi over 3 G rho
we said we could
write as 8 squared times omega.
And then we have minus kc
squared over a squared.
Note that we really have
here a tilde squared.
This is a squared divided
by k if I put them together.
So this term can be
written as minus c squared
over a tilde squared.
And this accomplishes
one of our goals.
It allows us to express a tilde
in terms of the quantities
that we want in our
answers, h and omega.
And if we can do
the same for theta,
we have everything we
need to express the age.
So the implication here
is that a tilde squared
is equal to c squared divided by
h squared times omega minus 1.
To take the square
root of that equation,
to find out what a
tilde is, we need
to think a little bit about
signs and things like that.
A tilde is always positive.
This is the scale factor
divided by the square root of k,
square root of k is
positive, scale factors
are always positive
the way we defined it.
So we can take the
square root of that
taking the positive square
root of the right hand side.
Omega is bigger than 1 for
our case, so omega minus 1
is a positive number, 8
squared is a positive number.
So taking the square root
there offers no real problem.
We can write a tilde
is equal to c over,
I guess this point I might
not notice until later.
h h can be positive or
negative over the course
of our calculation.
We're going to talk
about an expanding
phase and a contracting phase.
So when we take the
square root of h squared,
we want the positive number
to give us a positive a tilde.
So it's the positive
square root that we want,
which is the magnitude
of h, not necessarily h.
When h is positive, the
magnitude of h is h.
h could be negative though,
and the magnitude of h
is still positive, and then
the square root of omega
minus 1, which is
always positive.
So that's our formula for a
tilde in terms of h and omega.
OK, now we want
to evaluate alpha,
and I guess I did not keep
the formula for alpha quite as
long as we needed it.
When we defined alpha
in the first place,
let me remind you how it
was defined, 4 pi over 3 G
rho a tilde cubed
over c squared.
And that can be evaluated
using our formula for rho
and we'll put that in
for rho, and what we get
is c over 2 times
the magnitude of h
using this formula
for a tilde as well.
And then omega over omega
minus 1 to the 3/2 power.
Just using this
formula, and we know
how to express rho from
the right hand side,
and we know how to express a
tilde from this formula here.
So everything's straightforward,
and this is what we get.
And now I want to use these
to rewrite this equation,
a over the square root of
k is equal to alpha times 1
minus cosine theta.
I'm going to replace a over
root k by this formula.
I'm going to replace
alpha by that formula.
So this implies,
rewriting it, that c
over the magnitude of h times
the square root of omega
minus 1 is equal to c over twice
the magnitude of h times omega
minus 1 to the 3/2 power
times 1 minus cosine theta.
And now we've had to
survive some boring algebra.
But notice that now most
things cancel away here.
We get a very simple
relationship between theta
and h and omega,
actually just omega .
In particular,
when we solve that,
we get simply that
cosine theta is
equal to two minus
omega over omega.
So theta is directly
linked to omega.
If you know omega, you know
theta, If you know theta,
you know omega, by that formula.
And we can rewrite
this the other way
around by solving
for omega if we want.
Omega is equal to 2 over
1 plus cosine theta.
Now we can look at
this qualitatively
to understand how omega
is going to behave.
At the very beginning
cosine theta is equal to 1,
theta is equal to 0, so omega
is 2 over 1 plus 1, which is 1.
So at very early times
omega is driven to 1 even
in a closed universe.
As theta gets larger, cosine
theta gets less than 1.
This then becomes more than 1.
So omega starts to grow as
the universe starts to evolve.
At the turning point,
when the universe
has reached its maximum
size, theta is pi,
cosine theta is
minus 1, omega is
infinite at the turning point.
That may or may
not be a surprise.
But it you think about
it, it's obvious.
At the turning point h is 0,
therefore the critical density
is 0, but the actual
density is not 0.
And the only way the
actual density can be 0
while the critical
density is 0 is for omega
to be infinite, so we
should have expected that.
And then the return trip,
the collapsing phases,
a mirror image of
the expanding phase,
omega goes from infinity at
the turning point back to 1
at the moment of the Big Crunch.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm confused with
what the universe would
look like when it
gets to infinity.
PROFESSOR: It would look static.
It's temporarily static.
It's reached a
maximum size and is
about to turn around
and collapse, so h is 0.
AUDIENCE: OK, but
like with the density.
PROFESSOR: Well we could
calculate the density.
It's some number which
depends on alpha.
AUDIENCE: OK, but that
doesn't diverge or anything.
PROFESSOR: It doesn't
diverge or anything, no.
It's just some finite density.
At the turning point,
it's just a finite density
that can be expressed
in terms of alpha.
Sounds like a good
homework problem.
I think maybe I'll do that.
OK, so this now allows
us to express theta
as a function of omega,
which is what we wanted.
If we express theta as
a function of omega,
and alpha as a function of
omega and h, we have our answer.
We have t expressed as a
function of h and theta.
So there are choices about
how exactly to express omega
in terms of theta
that will involve
inverse trigonometric functions.
And anything that
can be expressed
in terms of an inverse
cosine, can also
be expressed as an
inverse sine by doing
a little bit of manipulations.
We have our choice here
about what we want to do.
But in any case,
the answer already
has a factor of
sine theta in it.
So it's most useful
to express theta
as the inverse sine of what
we get from that formula,
to express the answer
in what at least to me
is the simplest form.
So I'm going to manipulate
this a little bit
to find out what sine
theta is in terms of omega,
and then invert that to express
theta in terms of omega.
So sine theta is of
course plus or minus
the square root of 1 minus
cosine squared theta.
And cosine theta we
know in terms of omega,
so we can express this
in terms of omega.
And if you do that it's
straightforward enough algebra.
It's plus or minus, depending
on which sign of the square root
is relevant, and we'll talk
about that in a minute.
It's plus or minus the
square root of 2 times omega
minus 1 over omega.
So we can express theta
as the inverse sine
of this expression.
And now what I want to
do is to make use of this
to put into this expression
using the value for alpha
that we've already calculated
and wrote over there.
So we get our
final answer, which
is that t is equal
to omega over twice
the magnitude of the Hubble
expansion rate times omega
minus 1 to the 3/2 power
times the arc sine or inverse
sine of twice the square root
of omega minus 1 over omega.
That's just the theta that
appears in this formula written
in terms of sine theta or the
inverse sine of the quantity
that we determined
was the sine of theta.
And then I see here I
should have a plus or minus
because we haven't
figured out our signs yet.
Either is actually
possible, depending
on where we are
in the evolution.
And then minus or plus twice
the square root of omega
minus 1 over omega.
That's a plus or minus,
this is a minus or plus.
And the reason I wrote one
upstairs and one downstairs
is that we don't yet really
know how to evaluate theta,
but the sign of
this term is always
going to be the negative of
the sign of that term, this
or that minus sign.
So theta can be the inverse
sine of this expression
with either sign of the sine.
Sorry for the puns.
But whichever it is,
it's the same on there
as it is here but with a minus
sign in front, that minus sign.
OK, so this is our final
formula for the age.
But we still need to think a
little bit about the s-i-g-n
signs of these inverse
functions that appear here,
that and that, and
straightforward if you just
take it case by case.
And in the notes we
have a table which
I'll put shortly on the screen.
But let's start by just talking
about the earliest phase where
the universe is shortly
after the Big Bang,
so that the development
angle is a small angle.
We know that theta
is going to go
from 0 to 2 pi over the
lifetime of our universe.
So I now want to think
of theta being small.
And small means small compared
to any number you think about.
So when theta is small the
sine theta is nearly theta.
Both are positive.
And in that case the
sine theta being positive
means this is the positive
root in this equation,
and therefore the positive
root in that equation.
So for early times this
would be the plus sign,
and that would mean that
this would be the minus sign.
Again the minus sign
just coming from there
and theta being positive.
So for early times
it's a plus and minus.
And the arc sine is
itself ambiguous.
For early times
the angle we know
is going to be just a
little bit bigger than 0.
So that's the evaluation that we
make of the arc sine function.
Pi plus that would also
give us the same sine.
It would be another possible
value for the arc sine.
And of course 2 pi
plus that would also
be another possible root.
So you have to know
which root to take
to know the right answer
here because as an angle,
0 is equivalent to 2 pi,
but as a time, 0 is not
at all equivalent to 2 pi.
So you do have to know
the right one to take.
We'll continue doing that
on a case by case basis.
Those are the equations,
that's the formula for the age,
and that's the formula for the
age with a description of which
roots to take for each
case, which just comes out
by following the
evolution, we know
that theta is going
from 0 to 2 pi,
and this last column, the
inverse sine of the expression
which means the expression
that appears here.
For the smallest angle
is 0 to pi over 2.
We can think of this actually
as defining our columns.
Theta starts at 0 so the
time lengths between 0
and pi over 2, a time
length between pi over 2,
a time length between
pi and 3 pi over 2,
and a final time length
between 3 pi over 2 and 2 pi.
And the first two correspond to
the expanding phase, second two
correspond to the
contracting phase.
We can easily see
what values of omega
are relevant in those cases.
Omega we said
starts at 1 and gets
larger, the borderline where
the angle is pi over 2 one
could just plug
into these formulas
and see amounts
to omega equals 2.
So that is a division line
between these first two
quadrants just calculated
from the value of theta.
Omega then goes
to infinity as we
said, comes backwards
and back to 1 in the end.
And in this column
we just figure
out which sign
choice corresponds
to getting the right
value for omega
and the angle that
appears in the arc
sine of our formula for
the age, the formula there.
So any one of these I
claim is very obvious.
Seeing the whole
picture takes time
because I think you really
have to look at each case one
at a time to make sure you
understand it in detail.
But if you understand the
initial expanding phase
that's what corresponds
to our universe
if our universe were closed.
And the others are just as easy.
You just have to take them
one at a time I think.
OK, we're going to end there.
We will continue on Thursday.